jeudi le président de la république
assistera au gala de réouverture de la
comédie france fermée depuis deux ans le
théâtre français a été entièrement
rénovée du sol au plafond et si l'on va
continuer et joué les classiques molière
corneille racine
ce sera désormais avec l'aide de
l'ordinateur exceptionnel réuni pour à
deux les trois cyrano qui ont joué
devant 80000 spectateurs au palais des
congrès dernières représentations
buissonnière à vendre est intégré les
vieux murs tout neuf de la rue richelieu
les galeries sont prêtes et les socles
n'attendent plus que le retour des
statuts des grands auteurs les derniers
coups de pinceaux et les interminables
kilomètres de moquer trop au même titre
que ses parfums ou sa haute couture la
maison de molière et l'inde et prestige
de la france
pourtant cette vaste entreprise
nationalisée n'emploie que 334 personnes
dont 84 comédien voici la nouvelle salle
les mauvaises places et le poulet y ont
été supprimés
il reste 8 192 fauteuils confortables
en ce qui concerne les acteurs il n'y a
pas de véritable problème parce que ils
retrouvent leurs scènes avec des
conditions je crois acoustique améliorée
mais en ce qui concerne le personnel
technique une partie du personnel
technique
celui qui plonge un peu plus que les
autres dans dans la technicité a
certainement des problèmes parce que
nous avons un jeu d'orgue extrêmement
perfectionné un jeu d'orgue à mémoire
qui fonctionne électroniquement et qu'il
faut s'y habituer mais des stages ont
été faits et depuis le 15 septembre
nous sommes tout de même sur la
manoeuvre données
troisième mémoire terminées les
commandes manuelles aujourd'hui tout ou
presque et électroniques
ici le jeu d'orgue miniaturisés le
simple fait d'appuyer sur un bouton
permet sans éclairage instantanée
mémorisées dans une cassette que
l'ordinateur n'aura qu'à lire
autre avantage on pourra conserver les
cassettes et les réutiliser lors des
reprises deux ou trois ans après sans
faire de nouveau appel au metteur en
scène je suis à commugny française
depuis 26 ans et je ne pensais pas du
tout avoir l'électronique et la
télévision dans mon service est ce que
vous êtes habitué maintenant à cette
nouvelle technique
oui maintenant nous avons les choses
vraiment commencé en juillet 74 sous la
direction de l'architecte en chef louis
blanchet les travaux ont duré deux ans
et coûté 6 milliards et demi de centimes
il était indispensable car les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient plus
respectées
le théâtre n'avait pas subi de
transformations depuis l' incendie 1900
et cette rénovation a peut-être éviter
une nouvelle catastrophe sans que cesse
pour autant l'activité de 5
nous avons utilisé fermeté syndicale ce
que ces travaux soient menés tout en
garantissant l'emploi et le niveau des
revenus
c'est une chose une deuxième chose qui
nous satisfait beaucoup moins et là je
parle en tant que membre du comité
d'entreprise
c'est que ces travaux ont été menés
d'une façon qui ne nous satisfait
beaucoup moins c'est à dire que au lieu
d'avoir été consultés régulièrement et
attentivement sur ses travaux en fait
nous avons été informés c'est franco
zeffirelli cinéaste prestigieux de roméo
juliette qui met en scène de lorraine
axiaux de la réouverture tout comme le
héros de musset il est lui aussi né à
florence aimé ça
man bien équipée qui des possibilités
comme il faut aujourd'hui que c'était un
bon théâtre aussi avancé mais sable je
me trouve chez moi comme s'il y avait
toujours travaillé avec et c'est un
combat ni admirable des bons amis et des
grands g professionnel c'était ce qu'il
faut être absolument florentin pour
mettre en scène lorànt deutsch you c'est
la récente réforme des statuts qui a
permis à claude rich d'entre eux aux
français claude rich qui avait eu pierre
dux comme professeur au conservatoire a
signé un contrat de pensionnaires pour
un an sur un peu aux français comme
stagiaire quand j'étais élève au
conservatoire il y avait un temps j'ai
j'ai eu à ce bon prix je n'ai pas été
engagé et je suis engagé 20 ans après ça
ne rajeunit conservait pas c'était
toujours fait par des femmes
alors je ne m'étais jamais penchée sur
l'euro-dollar une voiture et là
eh bien je découvre l'organisation comme
un élève du conservatoire et tous un
passionnant des sciences te dire et ne
rien dire
habituée doucement l'imagination qui se
développe à donner des corps à ses
fantômes a touché ce qu'ils disent prêts
à mépriser ceux qui la protègent
cela va plus vite pour une passe de
vrais mairie et de frappe est riche et
le public
que pense-t-il de ce retour au bercail
cellule que le français le plus haut
d'un 10 de fréquentation et que pour
cyrano les 3700 places du palais des
congrès ont été à chaque fois prises
d'assaut même si je suis très contente
que la comédie comme chez dell partie si
c'est vraiment le nombre mais pas la
qualité
j'ai vu cyrano car une fois monsieur
donc eh bien c'est la seule fois où j'ai
vu le monde comme aujourd'hui vraiment
aujourd'hui c'est déplorable
je préfère la la comédie-française
richelieu
on ne se lassera un gage définitif parce
que j'aurai beaucoup de choses à dire
sur la façon dont la comédie française
joue les pièces interprète des pièces et
surtout sur le fait que la commission
cet effet pour une edith un théâtre tout
neuf une réputation mondiale pierre dux
cependant est obsédé par l'amélioration
de l'image de marque de la comédie l'a
baptisé vieille dame le fait bondy où
des ponts de l'intonation avec laquelle
roule 10 si on dit la vieille maison
avec tendresse je suis ravi mais quand
on dit
vieille dans le sens de trop vieux et ça
arrive quelques fois quand je suis pas
content tout sera prêt le jeudi 4
novembre quand le président de la
république s'installera dans sa loge la
seule qui était est conservé quand le
rideau se lèvera une vénérable dame de
300 ans commencera une nouvelle carrière